hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to depth now this game came
out a while ago and I never played it
because I find it [ __ ] terrifying
legitimately it's a game where you play
as a diver down deep in the ocean and
apparently other players can be the
Sharks and all the things go bad and you
die and it's just something that uh-huh
no I've never really been too much into
but I'm just gonna I'm gonna play cuz I
will [ __ ] you man oh God
see sub Nautica I've gotten used to it
because there aren't sharks in
subnautica there's shark like creatures
but there's not sharks in subnautica but
in this game it's literally sharks and I
[ __ ] hate sharks
I [ __ ] hate sharks among many things
that are in the ocean but sharks poop
are [ __ ] [ __ ] so I'm just in a
random multiplayer game because I feel
like if I was actually playing with my
friends it wouldn't be nearly as scary
what friend you guys gave no idea anyway
so I'm gonna be I'm gonna be fin Oh No
maybe oh god I have no idea how to play
I'm already sorry all my fellow
teammates I'm not gonna do well I'll get
the speargun I don't know I got no cash
I got a knife a knife or a a chivalry
knife either way this is gonna be good
good luck to me I guess this is gonna be
good sharks don't have putt bum bums are
like butts right indeed indeed a nice
simple buttocks
I mean sharks don't have buttholes yet
but I'm about in insert a bottle oh I
hate it already oh I hate it already oh
hi Steve okay I guess bye Steve okay I
guess oh no oh no my fellow crewmates
are already going insane I don't even
know what I'm supposed to do I don't
know [ __ ] no oh no oh no oh they're dead
why are they dead can anybody talk to me
I don't know how to voice communicate
but I imagine just probably bad oh my
god oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] what the [ __ ] - what the
[ __ ] [ __ ]
okay I'll respond by Steve haha holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] i ah [ __ ] is he in here
with me
I saw something oh my god okay I'm gonna
help I think oh god oh god oh god
[ __ ] god oh [ __ ] I killed a shark how
I didn't know I killed a shark yay we
did something oh good oh god oh god oh
good I love being here oh I love being
here oh I love being here but [ __ ]
where [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] I'm gonna get you I'm gonna get you
I'm gonna get you oh where you going
where you going buddy huh oh [ __ ]
that don't look good oh [ __ ] oh god oh
god oh god okay oh [ __ ] man that's so
[ __ ] oh my god why is that so [ __ ]
terrifying that is so terrifying holy
[ __ ]
cuz you have no idea where the [ __ ] they
are oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god I hate this I hate this oh
my god I hate this oh god where are they
oh I'm out in the open that's not good
oh god they're in there oh I got to
fight him gonna kill a shark I killed
one shark go kill another oh he's dead
okay captain Stubbs that's it a good
haul now [ __ ] just trying to read you
foot captain stuffs just talking to me
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] dude where are they oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] okay oh [ __ ] oh five [ __ ]
Steve all right Steve okay Steve oh [ __ ]
I [ __ ] you miss BAE [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] he's dead okay Steve is opening
that oh [ __ ] you gonna steal sharks now
that bottles but they said well I should
get in there that's probably important
oh god oh god oh god Steve don't kill
kill me I Eve [ __ ] know
[ __ ] you don't damage to you I dammit
you I killed you hey yes my guy is
[ __ ] not doing well but my boy my boy
oh ma boy
where'd you go my boy war my boy where'd
you go which go boy that's not
reassuring oh I hate this god this is so
stressful this way I didn't [ __ ] play
this game because it's [ __ ]
terrifying I hope everybody can hear me
right now oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god it did I
do that
I think I did that oh my god oh my god
oh my god him we got a five I don't know
if 5 means [ __ ] and me repairing Steve
I guess that's good hey Steve is IA [ __ ]
[ __ ] good god it's so sudden
that my butthole gotta stay mobile is
the thing that that guy was still
breathin a bit or maybe that was the
last breath we don't know oh boy oh boy
whoa oh boy good good good good on you
good on you ah man barf is tearing me
apart man it's good thing we can respawn
maybe I should buy more guy [ __ ] ah
[ __ ] gut damn it [ __ ] hell Jesus
Christ
okay Steve is on the way good job Steve
you want us all proud Steve don't
sprouts ah [ __ ]
God it gets me every [ __ ] time and
it's like this girliest cream I'm sorry
oh I don't
gotcha I think oh boy well I see you
over there
why is he jingle Belling jingle Belling
I don't know why he's jingle Belling
okay I got a harem I think oh god that
sounds bad but [ __ ] I 5 Bob I showed
it oh he's dead okay thank you for the
assist I think I'm bleeding profusely
I'll [ __ ] miss nale juh nope missed
again
nailed yeah gotcha hee hee hoo hoo and
this is actually pretty difficult for
the Sharks I imagine what is that some
sort of you can oh [ __ ] oh that [ __ ]
I walked right into that whoa
somehow alive is that is that I don't
know what that was did that help me [ __ ]
we're [ __ ] no
Oh got you barf her we got you as a team
together like friends do bearing sieve
preparing Steve yeah I'm almost dead
high-five dad okay I'm dead oh [ __ ] I
have no idea if I'm doing well or merely
mediocre or poorly all I know is that I
don't want to die oh there's a shirk
nearby isn't there
that means there's a shark nearby hey
okay oh that's that's handy the see mine
I blew up I blew up I blew up I blew up
whoa I thought I got a why no you know
oh god he's still alive he's doing
everybody he's doing haha
he's doing he did everybody he killed
ever how did he kill everybody because I
sucked ass and didn't shoot him that's
what happened that's how that we're no
repair and see prepare and Steve I don't
know if there's a good things I'm
supposed to be doing barber where's
Steve I care about Steve ah war [ __ ] so
I can I can I can dodge have I been
doing that I can doubt [ __ ] I gotta get
with my team that's what the hint says
gotta be with my team I see you there
whoa he's got somebody that's not good
whoa [ __ ] no come at me [ __ ] come at
me goddamn it behind me son of an ass oh
no I did bad but I didn't do as bad as
sharks don't have buttholes [ __ ] okay
well that was a thing her boy uh I don't
know how that went
I don't know what happened I unlocked
the twin pistols carrying two of these
the smart choice for bring more power to
the fight maybe the spear gun was like a
bad choice I have no idea oh okay oh
there's a lot of maps here I'm not okay
not okay my heart is going a million
miles an hour but I feel like I have to
do that again it just showed up but this
time I'm gonna go for a Megalodon hunt I
don't think it's gonna go well but can't
go any worse than it just did Oh at
least everyone seemed to be nice except
for all the murder that was happening
you know what okay I'm just gonna I'm
gonna find another match if I find
another match I'm gonna try not to
scream like a little girl so much
because that seems to be a problem of
mine every single time I think a shark
got me I screamed and that's
embarrassing so let's try to sack up a
little bit because it's not going too
well for me oh boy money money money I
don't have any money I've got seven I've
got 800 bucks it's all I got
welp spear pistol I did that so let me
try the the affordable choice cuz that's
what I want when my life is on the line
something affordable yeah pretty much
I'm ready okay
all right I guess really much else I can
do besides scream like a little baby oh
boy
god I really hope no one can hear me oh
hey guys hey how's it going
get ready to die a whole bunch ahh like
a lot mm-hmm yeah that's probably true
okay just got to kill me some sharks
it's gonna kill me some sharks and get
in there quick and kill me some jerks
good luck half in this guy's a funny guy
this guy's a funny one oh yeah Oh God Oh
God
okay all right okay that's not a good
place to be okay where's the shark OHS
oh [ __ ] what it's right there
[ __ ] of course I'm the first guy dead
of course
of course I'm the first guy dead okay
okay okay get back in there get Steve oh
boy shark is nearby huh whoa God
was that a shark wait did a shark whoa
oh God okay kill the sir [ __ ] Oh oh
wow I'm still alive I can't believe that
oh wow well that's not good I'm bleeding
so they probably know exactly where I am
I'm bleeding profusely I am literally
covered in blue oh that's not good
that's that's probably not good ah the
finest riches in Davy Jones locker let's
go find some more booty shall we yeah
let's do that
well that was quick
so apparently like we could go get some
stuff when is that okay picked up
treasure I like it I like it did Mami's
shred these sharks are a lot less blue
oh [ __ ] only four bullets I should
probably be careful about me shooting
this man the last sharks that we played
against we're aggressive as fiak whoa
[ __ ] they got me oh but your dad now
whoa I am bleed I'm blue D I'm blue D
very blue D so the point is to always
stay mobile while also not jumping
immediately into their jaws their gaping
maws I wish I had more shots than four
four seems like it'll like very few
shots to bring down into the depths you
know well I saw that wall god whoa
God Oh God oh he got him oh my god he
got him okay I'm in the wrong spot hey
yo yo you better get this yeah getting
this wall boy can't move I am very slow
right now
oh I'm a sitting deal look I'm sitting
dick ah [ __ ] I hate it I hate it I hate
it I [ __ ] what where and why well
woah holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] oh no
that's not good well well that
probably is painful Oh poop miss me I
think okay all right cast entry oh sure
I think this is going surprisingly well
all things considered Wow okay all right
then oh wow my god is that by me oh [ __ ]
it was holy [ __ ] how does that not get
me I they not get me oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh oh boy oh boy where
where old [ __ ] boy Oh gotcha
saved you saved your life did that I did
that that was me those maybe those me
those me I did all that
what oh one of the Sharks is
disconnected Oh apparently were winning
very much so that people is rage quail
ting okay all right starting to get dark
boyo
oh they got a bot now oh okay all right
then laughs sorry
Oh God oh [ __ ] okay these guys are much
better than I am I'm just lucky that I'm
along for the ride thank you all for
accommodating my levels of sock because
they are excessive and extreme oh god oh
god oh god the [ __ ] something blasted
that out oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god let me get him I got
him again amigo ah [ __ ]
wolf [ __ ] [ __ ] cool [ __ ] boy oh I
got that one
oh boy oh okay we're almost done I think
Steve's just bursting with loot he is
time to take this haul back to the boat
protect Steve with your lies okay thanks
captain Stubbs I don't know why we have
to but okay [ __ ] sorry Steve
oh boy Oh these jingling with all the
loot inside of him who is just jingling
with potential for loot they're floating
around here somewhere I don't know where
whoa [ __ ] I heard that wolf [ __ ] okay
why the [ __ ] way [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] did I dodge that feel like I dodged
that oh boy I [ __ ]
I don't see anything [ __ ] I saw nothing
no I feel nothing
I died damage to you that's what matters
I damned alleged oh [ __ ] save Steve save
Steve I do I better get a lot of money
out of this my the only one about Steve
I'm the only one around Steve why am i
doing oh god thank you I'm not the only
one around Steve dodge whoa damn yeah
[ __ ] repairing it oh my god stop it
holy [ __ ] got that one apparently I did
that that was good okay good
[ __ ] [ __ ] well yay I I think we did it
holy [ __ ] I think we did it oh my god
this [ __ ] oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
not over yet oh boy that's not good
that's not good okay where Steve's up
there all right yeah I got six kills
without dying Oh kill sis okay
well Elaine and pone beard seem to do a
lot better than I did but I still better
than atom bomb by only a little bit by
small metrics it's too bad the other guy
disconnected but he was the better one
after all I don't know why he
disconnected wooof 16 kills his diver is
that good I have no idea yeah when you
win brag about it that lets make a good
player I guess okay so anyway that is
depth [ __ ] oh man that games so scary
I've never played that game before in my
life but I can see the appeal it's
freaking horrifying in every way but you
know it's okay maybe I should have taken
the tutorial maybe that would've been a
good idea I just like diving into you
know I made a little pun action over
there but either way thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know what
you thought down the comments below
oh if you want to see more of this maybe
with our friends let us know as well
what's [ __ ] terrifying so anyway
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye
[Music]
[Music]